hey everyone this is Paul my fiancee
everyone meet Paul Michael Paul Michael
meet well everyone what's up
amanda bynes hit up Instagram on
Thursday to introduce her soon-to-be
hubby to her fans hey everyone this is
Paul my fiancee what's up I'm so lucky
as you can see he's also the best person
with a spirit the 33 year old also took
a beat to apologize to all the people
she might have offended on social media
over the years including Drake and
Chrissy Teigen who she famously called
ugly I just wanted to post a video to
say I'm sorry to everyone who might
called ugly on Twitter I was feeling so
ugly at the time and it was really hard
for me to express myself at the time
because I was so drugged out now Amanda
says she's doing a-okay and both she and
her man are enjoying the sober life I've
remained sober for over a year same with
the Pope and I just want to let you know
that I love you guys and I'm so happy
now I feel like I got what's mine and
that is Pole prior to making the
official insta intro Amanda shared this
pic with Paul writing my love is Paul
the former child star shocked fans with
her surprise engagement news on
Valentine's Day posting this pic of her
sparkly bling alongside the caption
engaged to the love of my life then she
shared this shot with Paul writing lover
stop Instagram just wanted to say hi to
all of my followers I really wanted to
say I appreciate you guys so much for
supporting me a source told ET earlier
this week that Amanda met the 28 year
old when they were in the same sober
living facility more than two months ago
and on Wednesday ET learned that
Amanda's parents haven't met him yet the
source also shared that after Amanda
checked out of a sober living facility
on her own on December 12th the judge in
her conservatorship case ordered her to
return to sober living Amanda is
currently under a conservatorship and
can't actually legally get married
unless a judge and her mom sign off on
the nuptials
the actress has been pretty candid about
her past struggles with drug abuse and
mental health in 2018 she talked to
paper magazine about addiction and at
the time she talked about creating a
fashion line but noted she wanted to
return to acting first superstar singing
sensation chief these Springs Beatty has
talked with some of Amanda's former
co-stars over the years about how she's
doing including Nick Cannon who she
starred with on all that five years ago
you wrote this open letter to amanda
Bynes oh yeah yeah I'm the biggest
Amanda Bynes fan like watching that girl
absolutely how do you talk to her as a
recently I haven't but I heard she's
doing so much better and that's I mean
people when they're weird when they're
dealing with personal issues sometimes
you got to give him that space yeah and
then when they reach out then that's the
time to do it so she knows and you know
I always to open invite whenever she
needs anything I'm career or even
personally I'm here I would love a
comeback game he wanted her were you
trying to get her on wild and out we had
to all that reunion and that's kind of
when I knew like okay she's still she's
still working on herself and which is
the outstanding thing but you know she's
always welcome that's a little sis right
there and Channing Tatum her she's the
man co-star also had something to say I
love her I'm so happy she's like killing
it again and just back to back on on the
right like it's she's so talented and so
special and she's been doing it I mean
like I think it's so impossible when you
start at such a young age to keep like
perspective when somebody comes back and
fights their way back to where she is
today what do you remember most about
that time and that experience doing that
movie she was just so alive like I mean
when I say like you never knew what was
gonna come out of her mouth like you she
was just like on fire
that's I don't know I haven't seen her
in so long I hope I love you man and I
hope you over there is a lot of support
and love surrounding Amanda and we love
to see that if you or someone you know
is struggling with addiction just
remember there is help out there for all
the latest on Amanda Bynes be sure to
stick with all things et until next time
I'm Hallie Stevens see you soon
[Music]